Today we are making some sourdough discard goldfish for my toddler.
I actually have this core memory of myself when I was pregnant
towards the end, that I was like,
I wanna be that mom that makes everything from scratch for her kids.
And I just had no idea how I was gonna do it,
because I truly did not make anything really
from scratch when I was pregnant.
And I was just looking back while I was making this for my daughter,
and I just, like,
was like, wow,
I'm so proud of myself, because truly,
I've came a long way. And
I can't believe I'm making all these foods from scratch
for my toddler,
and I can't believe I've Learned how to do all this on my own.
So that is a reminder that you can go from not cooking from scratch,
not knowing how to cook, to completely changing it around and learning.